hello everyone lastly once you drew his
game yesterday against Vladimir Kramnik
in the World Cup and he might've had the
white pieces so today he went to has a
tremendous task in front of him he has
to face former world champion Vladimir
Kramnik with the black pieces and that
is not another small thing to do
as Kramnik with the white pieces is well
pretty much unbeatable so it all depends
will Chucky have a good day or not but
this game I have prepared for you today
this is the London Grand Prix blitz
finals in 1994 played between whis wanna
turn on and Vasiliev on Chuck where as
you've seen from the title event to mrs.
a making one but till that moment on and
it really does feel the extent of Chuck
is wrath so let's see this a game as it
is a pretty amazing game since it's a
blitz game Alan goes efore and we have
c6 by von Schuch the car walk on defense
we have Knight see 3d 5d 4d captures on
e4 knife captures on e4 937 and Bishop
to c4 we have an IG to f6 and unplaced
Knight to g5 and of course this isn't
the checkmate Chuck you would have
bishop to f7 this is just a line we have
e six now defending and iron goes Queen
to e2 and this is a blitz game and
although this is a pretty famous line
you do have to be careful here if you
play something like g6 for example in
this position you get Knight captures on
f7 and if King captures simply Queen
captures an e6 would check King to g7
and Queen f7 is checkmate
so a tricky variation if you're not
familiar with it so of course you want
to place the Knights to b6
now this Bishop is defending this e six
pawn and also attacking the knight is
attacking the bishop here so we have
Bishop to b3 h6 kicking this night we
have night 5 2 F 3 and the event took
place
c5 we have Bishop to 4 and Knight B to
d5 now attacking that Bishop on f4 we
have a Bishop to e5 and now Queen to a5
with check we have nice - D - and now b5
if I truck is threatening to move c4 to
drive this Bishop on v3 so we have D
captures on c5 by Island and the bishop
captures on c5 so developing a bishop
would a temple we have nice to f3 and
the Avenger castles and on and castles
Queen side although a bit safe it was
safer to Castle kingside here but Anand
wants to attack on the Kings side so we
have twin side castle and we have a
bishop to b7
I don't place G for preparing g5 we have
Knight to d7 and that we do have g5 by
Anand Knight captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 and in this position well
sufficient would be to play H captures
and g5 and this would be okay for
Evangel but he even took census the the
power of the blacks position here and
although it's a blitz game he finds a
very interesting move
he plays Knight to c3 and this is
attacking the Queen I need to but also
this pawn on a 2 twice and let's see
what happens if I don't would capture
this night if B characters on c3 you'd
get Bishop to a3 check King to be 1 and
now Queen captures on c3 and now Chuckie
would be threatening Queen to be to
checkmate
so you do have to stop this for example
Knight to b3 but here look a to d8
and the thread is of course capturing
this night and checkmating and b2 so
white would have to play something like
Queen to e5 threatening to exchange
Queens and after Queen captures Knight
captures simply Bishop captures on h1
and after rook captures on h1 or any
other move if ro captures and will
capture sandy - so even truck will be
objects change here and this would be
completely winning for black so I don't
of course Saudis and after Knight to c3
Anand didn't capture the night he played
Queen to g4 and we have Knight captures
on a - Bishop captures any - and now
eventually doesn't capture the bishop
because he doesn't want to allow if he
if he captures the bishop for example
you get G captures on h6 threatening
checkmate and g7 and after g6 simply
Knight captures here and while this is
completely completely when
for white for example you can't capture
the night or you'd get checkmated for
example king gage 798 check Bishop
captures and I fade and now rock to g1
and wow this is much better for white
so after this Bishop - 8 - Yvonne Chuck
doesn't capture he plays h5 first
getting a tempo on the Queen we have
Queen captures on h5 and only now Queen
captures on a - we have Knight to b3
Bishop to f2 capturing that allowing
rope to g1 rook to d3 and now and is
preparing rook to h3 and well this would
be a deadly threat but if one trick
actually allows this place rook the c8
and Eva Anand immediately plays rook the
rook to h3 and now he's threatening
checkmate on h7 or Naha - depending on
what black place but this was actually
one ship said yeah he plays rook
captures and c2 with check and here we
have King captures and c2 a story on c2
and we have utter rockin c8 check King
to d1 and we have a queen to be one
check we have King King to eat - now
Queen to f4 check and Anand captures the
bishop King captures on f2 and now rook
the C to check and I don't plays King to
f1 and this is the beautiful critical
position of the game in this position
event you had about 50 seconds left on
the clock and well he does have this
move Queen captures rook on h1 and this
is instant checkmate
but event you didn't see this move and
he spent a lot of time here and well he
got very low on time and in this
position he played Queen to f4 check he
completely missed Queen captures on h1
and which I find very fascinating
because if if this wasn't his plan if
this position I mean the captured rook
wasn't where he was going what he was
going for then it's like he achieved
this position intuitively so it wasn't
calculated so he didn't play Queen
captures on each one he played Queen to
f4 check and we have Knight to f3 by
Anand and already here on this much
better event replace clink to f/8
avoiding checkmate on h8 we have g6 by
Anand Quinta c4 and here event was at
about I don't know maybe 15 seconds so
he's just checking checking the White
King like crazy King to g1 we have Queen
captures on b3 he gets back the peace
Queen to e5
we have wrote the c1 check King to F -
Quinta C to check King to e3 and now
Queen to b3 check King to e - Quinta c4
check King to f2 Queen to c2 check you
want to be strike anything because he's
really long time a couple of seconds
only on the clock a king 33 now Queen to
b3 check King to f4 now rook the c4
check and now Knights to the four by
Anand Anand doesn't really carry magic
has only two or three seconds on the
clock he on gives up the rook here we
have Queen captures rook on h3 Allen
plays Queen to b8 with chick we have
worked the c8 and now Queen to d6 check
and event took place King to g8 and in
this position Avant chip is actually
completely in a winning position as well
in this position you want to be actually
lost on time but if you didn't I mean
this is a completely winning position
for black as how you would get G
captures here King captures Queen to d7
check King f6 and there really isn't a
good move for white here if Queen
captures some b7 then simply for if I
would check would would would an attack
on the night and also the queen is now
defending this rock and c8 so black is
getting made it here
King be for Queen g4 check came to be 3e
captures before with check King d3 Queen
h3 with check king d 2:23 king D 1 and
wrote the c1 check so but doesn't really
matter because on would never play such
moves if he didn't see that event would
lose on time but yeah nevertheless after
the move King to g8 in vanships time hit
zero and
that was the victor so yeah definitely
an amazing game and it's well things
like this do happen I mean 50 seconds on
the clock and not seen Queen captures on
each one that's pretty amazing but
that's just how chalky rolls you know
his demon so we're running wild and yeah
I will put the link in the description
below to the original video so you can
enjoy some young Maurice Ashley
commentary with this game if you want to
it's it's pretty good so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank David Chadwick for a
contribution to my channel I really
appreciate it thank you a lot and yeah
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here and thank you for watching I
will see you soon